hi Samuel leaves here and on this video
I'm going to talk to you a bit about
your power team so if you know that you
need to put a Power Team in place but
you're not sure exactly who that entails
then stay tuned the problem with not
having a Power Team if you do everything
yourself is that even if you are
successful and you get some deals you
stop making money it's not financial
freedom it's just a rope around your
neck I know some people that have got
over a hundred houses but to me I look
at them and I just think you've actually
got over a hundred headaches it's not
passive income at all people say I need
to buy near my house so that I can
manage it and keep an eye on the
property well that's not called
financial freedom that's called a rope
around your neck so who do you need in
your power team in order to succeed well
some of the some of these people are
just really obvious let me tell you who
you need in your Power Team you are
gonna need it's just kind of a
coincidence that it spells my name maybe
you will need me maybe only training but
these are the people you're gonna need
in your power team to buy and to manage
properties so the first person is before
you buy a house you need to get a
solicitor and the solicitor will of
course exchange complete on the property
they'll do all the searches there make
sure that there's no flying leaseholds
or anything like that
there's no mineshaft some of the
property really really important one of
the things I really love about property
investing is people say I'm scared I
might buy a lemon but when you've got
the right panel team you shouldn't buy a
lemon so that's the first one next if
you're buying a big portfolio and you're
growing it you want to make sure that
you not only earn as much money as you
can but also you have an accountant to
make sure that you keep as much money as
you can as well with section 24 the tax
changes you want to make sure you've got
a really good accountant someone to be
able to give you bespoke tax advice to
mean that you've got the maximum amount
of profit in your pocket at the end of
every month next now sometimes when
people want to buy property I'd never
advise buying a cash
if you bite cash so you buy a house for
a hundred thousand pound cash all your
money's tied up so you want to leverage
that you want to leverage that by
borrowing money from banks now don't do
what a lot of amateur investors do which
is literally go to their bank and say
I'm looking at buying a house can you
give me some money because they might
say no it takes a lot of time and even
if they say yes you probably haven't got
the best deal that you need so it's
really important that you have a
mortgage broker somebody who can look at
Indian independent mortgage broker
somebody who can look at all the
different loans look at your setup and
give you the best type of lending for
you for the best rates that's possible
right now
interest rates are very low you can fix
them for quite a long time get a good
mortgage broker next in order to buy a
good deal it makes sense you can try and
find all the deals yourself but it makes
sense to make friends with at least one
really good estate agent and what
they'll be able to do is they'll be able
to bring you off market deals they'll be
able to negotiate for you they'll be
able to advise you of the area estate
agents are worth their weight in gold
when you have the right estate agents
working for you that understand you at
understand property investments so it's
a really important person to have in
your team in order to help you find the
best property deals in the first place
next absolutely crucial vital critical
is that you have a letting agent as
someone who's going to manage the
property for you if it's a HMO property
you don't need a normal letting agent
you're going to require a special HMO
manager because sometimes the letting
agent will say to you yeah we do hate
your Moe's no you need someone that
specializes in hate your Moe's but
you're going to need someone to manage
the property to deal with the lettings
to deal with the collecting of the rent
the management the whole thing they'll
also do a lot of checks make sure that
you've got your EPC that kind of stuff
as well for you really really important
and then lastly is a builder if you're
in developments then you might need a
whole building team or construction team
architects things like that but
start now you're gonna need someone just
to be able to maintain the property even
if it's just a case of putting fire door
smoke alarms things like that so this is
your complete power team but none of
this will work if you don't so put these
together get out there make it happen
think they absolutely love about the
property investing as a business and
I've got several businesses and some of
them are worth quite a lot of money but
the thing I love about my property
investment business is that you don't
really need staff I mean we have got
some stuff but it took a very long time
before we employed people for our
property investment business because
when you buy a house you pay the estate
engine on results
you pay the Builder for his work and
usually he'll be a subcontractor
mortgage broker paid on resorts
accountant you'll pay him just a you
don't have to employ an accountant
you'll pay him you know per year per
annum for doing your all your books and
accounts so lets you do you pay them on
results if you pay them and then the
house falls through
you can often transfer it to another
property letting agent oh they're just
the best you pay them a percentage of
the rent and they do everything they
find the tenant they mop the market they
find the tenant they put the term in
there they give them the keys they
manage it they collect the rent they
chase the rent no the debt collector
they they'll send you a statement they
did everything and you don't have to
employ anybody so I think property
investing is the best vehicle to
financially to become financially free
for the average person there is however
you can have all these people in your
power team you have the best power team
ever but they won't work if you don't
work so get started
put together your power to him start
finding deals make it happen my own
Samuel Leeds I look forward to seeing
you next time thank you so much for
watching if you benefited from that
video please do share it with your
family and friends for more videos like
it you can watch right here and if you'd
like to spend two days with me at the
property investors crash course watch
this video see what happens
but whatever you do don't forget to
subscribe right here and I'll see you
next time